[Musique]
chers amis chers amis bonsoir c'est
l'heure du best-of de r d hergé le seul
jt de la culture interview critiqué
chronique images et reportages revivez
revoyez le meilleur de la culture sous
toutes ses coutures
c'est révoltant de constater l'opprobre
dans lequel depuis sa mort et est même
un peu de son vivant a vécu et vit
marcel aymé le mal aimé
on peut dire et vendredi on fêtera le
centième anniversaire de sa naissance
pas un mot c'est il a rassemblé sur
lui-même son père cité dnd vindicte
extraordinaire celle de la droite comme
celles de la gauche
et pourquoi puisque tous posent toujours
foutu pays en termes politiques comme ça
mais parce qu'il a parce que il a été
sans pitié pour l'une comme pour l'autre
mais la belle affaire sans vous à la
limite est simple coureur sans pitié
pour l'une comme pour l'autre donc
rejeté par l'une et l'autre et c'est
vrai qu'il a provoqué c'est vrai qu'il
ya des ambiguïtés chez lui mais enfin on
a quand même à quasiment accusés d'avoir
collaboré avec les allemands tout ça
parce qu'il avait été telle il était
viscéralement anti communiste et il a
fallu que le conseil c'est l'écrivain la
libération le prêt de sa défense et
atteste actes même qu'il n'avait pas
commis le moindre acte de collaboration
pour qu'il échappe
j'allais dire à l'échafaud enfin en tout
cas l'épuration il n'a pas qu'ils
n'étaient pas que la bratter mais on l'a
accusé d'avoir collaboré c'était
vraiment il a été victime de
tous les préjugés politiques de l'après
guerre et par là même d'une censure et
alors on finit par extrapoler et par
fantasmes et vous essayez de trouver
aujourd'hui j'en ai fait l'expérience
j'ai perdu ce temps rapide vous essayez
de trouver dans une librairie le confort
intellectuel vous ne le trouvez pas les
meilleurs libraire vous du tout mais on
pense que ça va être édité au mois de
mai mais c'est quand même extraordinaire
quand même totalement inadmissible enfin
on pose je pose la question à l'émission
prince est mon bref alors un écrivain
j'ai dit un esprit très libre des
écrivains les plus originaux et les plus
moches je suis pas aimé la trt mais
enfin quand même des plus féconds du
xxème siècle une oeuvre considérable une
personnalité une richesse considérable
romancier alors vous pouvez demander
qu'est-ce que ça ce que vous aimez bien
poser ces questions vous avez raison ce
que vous allez bien parce que j'ai
raison qu'est ce qui faut lire non mais
c'est ce qu'il faut dire silhouette du
scandale par ailleurs car on trouve en
folio c'est vrai la plupart de ses
heures il faut lire la jument verte
là vous ivre chez parce que frédéric ans
devenu conteur superbe les contes du
chat perché c'est magnifique passe
muraille polémiste satiriste et c'est ça
qu'on lui a jamais pardonné d'ailleurs
prêtent pas être du fantastique
dramaturge un théâtre l'hiver b soit
satirique avec les rangs barlin est le
boucher chose car ce que les tubes
lorsque vous dites quand même c'est déjà
pas mal et c'est que béthune qui les lie
on se retrouve pour moi l'interview
portrait aujourd'hui bartabas qui ouvre
son académie du spectacle équestre dans
les grandes écuries du château de
versailles pour soir
alors avant d'en parler je vous rappeler
comme ça quelques phrases que vous avez
prononcé sur le cheval est sur vous et
je vous demandais des commenté vous
dites par exemple je ne suis pas l'homme
qui murmure à l'oreille des chevaux mais
celui qui les écoutent oui parce que
c'est un peu paradoxal faire du théâtre
avec des animaux qui ne parlent pas
comme tout moyen émoussé sa demande
d'autant plus d'écouté plus je pense que
mon lait chaud on appris
multitude de choses mais si je devais en
choisir une ce serait ça c'est ils m'ont
appris à écouter je pense que onze début
de 21e siècle c'est important parce que
tout le monde parle tout le monde a
accès à l'expression mais personne ne
s'écoutent ch pensez-vous
alors vous dites avec les chevaux la
technique n'a de valeur que si derrière
il y a une vraie histoire une émotion
c'est comme avec les gens dont vous
arriver à créer avec les avec les
chevaux une vraie relation bien sûr
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'échelle la
technique est indispensable mais n'y a
pas d'échelle bon exemple pour moi monté
à cheval c'est facile de courir le 100 m
c'est plus difficile pour karl et oui ce
serait peut-être le contraire donc ce
qui compte surtout c'est la qualité de
la relation ce qu'on apprend par
soi-même en fait c'est le cheval j'ai
toujours été un miroir c'est vous
renvoie votre image là il vous renvoie
ce que vous avez été capable de
construire avec lui vous dit le cheval
quand vous le monte il devient une
partie de votre corps ouais bah ça c'est
le phénomène
c'est ce qui est très important dans la
raquette c'est qu'on est sur un animal
et donc on communique par moi je dis
qu'à haut niveau on communique par là
par l'esprit quoi c'est à dire que le
corps s'est tellement habitué les codes
se sont tellement construit que on pense
à un mouvement le cheval exécuter
quelques pas et devient un prolongement
de soi même c'est vrai que c'est le seul
animal avec qui on fait ça finalement
bah oui non mais c'est vrai moi j'y
pense souvent quand je suis sur d'autres
à cheval je me dis ça je me dis que
c'est seul moment on est sur une autre
bête quoi voilà et puis on communique
par le corps mais c'est juste alors j'ai
vu parfois dans le regard d'un cheval la
beauté inhumaines d'un monde avant le
passage des hommes
est ce que ça veut dire que ces décès
des préoccupations que j'ai beaucoup
maintenant si je me dis depuis le temps
que je travaille avec des chevaux
parfois quand je croise le regard le
matin tôt aux écuries je me dis non il
te regarde une manière les niveaux toi
tu t'excites ces petites choses sur
terre des petits spectacles extra et ils
ont l'air de dire c'est peut-être pas ça
le plus important est qu'on soit croyant
ou non on peut dire que l'homme est le
dernier animal créé sur terre donc
quelque part le cheval entre autres est
plus proche des origines le plus proche
de l'instinct alors ça c'est très
intéressant s'il faire asseoir un cheval
rien de plus facile
mais faire qu'un cheval ait envie de
s'asseoir de c'est ça qui est beau oui
c'est pas exactement ça disons que on
parle d'art et caisse dans la mesure où
il s'agit pas d'apprendre à l'animal à
faire un mouvement ça pouvait le faire
avec un caniche ou un éléphant man où il
donnerait un sucre ou ou un bout de
salade ou un bout de viande pour un pti
que j'en sais rien 6 il a bien fait pour
les hommes c'est pareil si travail mais
il a un bon salaire
là il s'agit surtout de travailler sur
la qualité du geste face actuellement à
prendre un geste c'est le restituer avec
émotion quoi en ça on peut parler d'art
équestre justement alors on va parler
d'art équestre
vous êtes ici pour l'ouverture de
l'académie du spectacle équestre dans
les grandes écuries du château de
versailles
alors d'abord l'endroit dessiné par
mansart à réhabiliter ça va l'être mais
vous voulez conserver à côté un peu
décrépis comme aux bouffes du nord
oui bah c'est à dire que laly l'idée
avec patrick bouchain qui est mon
architecte avec qui on a construit le
théâtre zingaro à aubervilliers
c'est pas du tout d'essayer de
reconstituer mais plutôt de trouver un
esprit est en fait à versailles on s'est
aperçu très souvent que à l'époque on
appelait ça des constructions éphémères
sauf que l'éphémère à l'époque c'était
quand même avec des charges et il ya eu
beaucoup de choses comme ça des granges
éphémère des décors éphémères et donc
c'était ici de reconstituer ça plutôt
que de vouloir rendre ce jeudi comme à
vide maintenant quand même et qui a été
quand même mal traités depuis plusieurs
siècles d'essayer de le reconstituer
d'une manière pas très intéressante donc
mais les ça va dans l'esprit de l'école
qu'il s'agit pas du tout à la
reconstitution historique justement mais
ça servait à quoi pendant toutes ces
années on voit sa série de beaucoup de
choses de bibliothèques de tennis de la
wii j'en passe et des meilleurs alors
justement vous n'étiez pas question de
faire de la reconstitution etc
c'est vrai qu'il ya un autre projet qui
était en opposition avec votre projet
beaucoup de projets particulièrement de
l'écuyer michel henrique il était super
par le cadre noir de saumur et qui était
beaucoup plus traditionnel que vous je
dirais non pas vraiment ce type car
venant justement assez apparemment oui
enfin c'est des noms si vous voulez
vider l'idée c'est de dire que le projet
n'est pas du tout traditionnelle dans la
dans le sens où les cultes à sion a
beaucoup évolué quoi bon pour en parler
on le 20e siècle est le siècle l'homme a
abandonné cheval une compagnons de
guerre plus compagnon de transport plus
compagnon de travail et je dirais même
qu enfin de xxème siècle on veut dire
que l'homme a abandonné le cheval aux
femmes même
c'est à dire qu'il n'est même plus un
bol de pouvoir de puissance rényon voir
l'avion s'il avait moyen donc et ça va
devenir d'ailleurs très intéressant
c'est que je pense les hommes comme les
femmes vont maintenant chercher dans le
rapport au cheval autre chose que la
puissance la représentation quoi mais
alors en ça c'est assez de nouveau c'est
à dire que entre autres à travers le
spectacle dont j'ai vu cette nécessité
de on n'a pas le rapt est tout à l'heure
par rapport à une gare en mai mais le
dossier aussi intéressante c'est en cela
ses traditionnels parce qu'il ya eu
effectivement le sec le siècle d'or on
pourrait dire de dollar et qu'est ce qui
s'appelle écoles de versailles à
l'époque de louis xiv
mais justement il faut bien voir qu'à
cette époque là ça s'adressait à des
jambons ce n'était pas tellement
démocrate démocratique mais ça
s'adressait à des gens qui avaient
justement une formation artistique c'est
à dire que l'équitation faisait partie
au même titre que la musique la danse
n'est pas que que louis xiv était un
grand danseur professionnel jeudi ils
avaient le niveau d'un danseur
professionnel
donc c'est des gens qui s'intéressait
aux autres arrêts entre autres à
l'équitation c'est pour ça que projet à
ce point là plus tard c'est devenu
d'équitation militaire la chaire à canon
pour les pour les charges de cavalerie à
l'eonia nous fallait former très vite
des cavaliers pourra les aider faire
descendre sur les champs de bataille est
donc l'équitation a dégénéré dans un
certain sens quoi à cause des militaires
justement donc en ce sens cela c'est
quelque part assez traditionnel puisque
on n'a qu'à des l'originalité cette
académie séance allait complètement
nouvelle cessé de dire qu' elle
s'adresse à des gens qui ont déjà des
très bonnes bases et caisses mais
justement de les éveiller à d'autres
arts c'est à dire que les 1 tiers du
temps sera le travail des shows public
et l'autre tiers l'école est fermée et
elle sert d'elle c'est pour les élèves à
travailler le chant la danse inscrits
n'ont justement pas forcément pour en
faire des chanteurs ou des danseurs mais
pour les éveiller à l'arrêt ce qu'on
peut dire que le milieu du cheval est
quand même eu lieu avec eux hier mais
bon en ça c'est pas très original parce
que tout conservatoire tout académie de
théâtre ou de danse travaille aussi le
chant d'autres disciplines
accessoirement bien alors les visiteurs
du château pourront assister le travail
des jours maintenant c'est très
intéressant aussi pas des courses et le
train circule et les écuyères vont
travailler leurs chevaux à vous dites
les écuyères oui parce que le problème
plutôt des femmes bas c'est à dire que
en fait on en 30 ans est
sociologiquement c'est intéressant dans
trente ans on est passé dans le monde et
et quittant ses atouts rapport avec le
cheval qu'ils soient professionnels
amateurs tourisme on est passé de 70%
d'hommes à 30% de femmes il ya trente
ans maintenant 85 % de femmes et 15% des
marais où ça je le disais que l'homme a
réglé le cheval aux femmes et donc pour
être un peu en phase d'avoir accès avec
ce phénomène
j'ai souhaité puis en plus par
provocation un peu par les autres et
quand vous connaît en tous les cas donc
ce centre sera ouvert à la création
contemporaine et quand on vous pose la
question où louis louis xiv il faisait
travailler
lully molière qui était sa des éléments
qui m'a décidé à ouvrir cette école à
cet endroit c'est la rencontre avec
hubert astier qui est le directeur du
conservatoire de l'établissement de
versailles qui tout de suite mam a
expliqué que sa politique à versailles
était justement d'essayer de développer
le côté culturel et pas dans le sens
comme ça c'est dans tous les châteaux la
reconstitution historique du son et
lumière et xavier pas trop de mains
staline un peu de la vie ouais ça ouvre
deux camps alors j'ai bien ça ouvre en
2003 en février 2003 avait dans un an
quoi on en fera 18 ans 1 entre 18 et 26
ans voilà il faut avoir donc déjà une
certaine pratique de l'art équestre mais
un bon niveau
un bon niveau alors c'est assez
versailles bravo parce que c'est quand
même nom mais bon vous savez c'est pour
moi c'est surtout c'est surtout le
résultat d'un questionnement depuis
presque 20 ans et depuis 20 ans avec le
théâtre zingaro je m'aperçois que
j'oublie de former les propres cavaliers
pour cette raison parce qu'il n'ya pas
d'école qui forment on a peut créer une
forme de spectacle qui n'existait pas on
pourrait dire d'une certaine manière et
donc
la chorégraphe ou un ouragan scène il
peut servir dans l'est dans les écoles
oui mais en tous les cas de la part des
gens qui vous ont choisi ça prouve une
belle ouverture d'esprit je trouve bien
sûr maman c'est un moment je sais que je
passais dépôt grand chose mais catherine
tasca et c'est vrai que ça me vous
mettre vous à cet endroit là je trouve
que ça prouve que tout n'est pas figé et
tout n'est pas complètement
réactionnaire donc à part ça y est
toujours le circuit ngabo faut remonter
à 0 et est offert deux berlines et on se
sent place quand même sur vos 35 saint
laurent soit 165 parce qu'elle touche ou
du prochain spectacle parce que ça c'est
un élément aussi important les de
l'académie une des raisons qui m'ont
décidé à le faire c'est que de plus en
plus on a ce problème là cirque à chaque
spectacle maintenant j'essaie de faire
un bond très différents et c'est un gros
investissement de travailler par exemple
il ya vache folle ont été formés
spécialement pour triptyque qui sont
encore de jeunes chevaux qui ont déjà un
investissement de travail énorme mais je
ne pourrais pas réutilisé dans la
prochaine création et donc l'académie va
aussi servir à pouvoir utiliser ces
chevaux parce que j'ai beaucoup de mal à
me séparer au sud mais échoue savoir
fait aussi à des bouchers alors c'est
une histoire incroyable théâtre zingaro
un jour en 89 de les voir le maire
jacques ravi teneur de verviers avec une
maquette sous le bras ville voilà j'ai
repéré un terrain vague
est ce que je pourrais m'installer là
au départ c'était provisoire c'était
c'était pour six mois et puis vous êtes
resté mais ça fait 13 ans raconte enfin
signalons existait déjà depuis quatre
cinq ans mais je reconnais que le maire
enfin moi je travaille beaucoup comme ça
si elle je dis jamais attendu ni les
nominations des subventions il ya un
moment où il faut faire les choses il
faut les faire et donc ça doit passer
comme ça tout s'est passé mais c'est
vrai qu'on vous nous avez fait vivre des
moments extraordinaires mais je suis la
première fois que je suis allé c'était
vraiment un des plus grands chocs de ma
vie on est rentré il y avait là la
paille avec le lusc à la violence mais
il y avait le veulent fameux vin chaud
conservés dans les dents les samovar
qu'on buvait dans les dents et pick up
et puis vous avez eu cette réaction qui
est tout à fait bien vous avez dit
attendez il faudrait quand même pas que
le cirque zingaro que le théâtre zingaro
pardon cette veine l'endroit ou à boire
du vin chaud voilà ça y est tu râles le
trucage je donnerai pas de titre à mes
spectacles
trois créations qui était assez
différent dans le contenu mais la forme
était la même et c'est vrai que ça
devenait un peu ah bah oui c'est
quelqu'un qu'on voit du vin chaud et bon
j'aurais pu devenir le lido du théâtre
équestre ouvert laissant clairement
proposé par tous mais bon c'est pas du
tout j'aime bien ces avancées comme la
recherche
ouais on va regarder le spectacle triste
est que magnéto
[Musique]
triptyque donc au théâtre zingaro alors
la troupe habitent dans des dans les
caravanes à autour du théâtre et et vous
dites c'est pas le genre de boulot ou et
on peut bosser rentrée après la maison
quoi il faut oui disons que j'ai
toujours dit que pour moi le théâtre
d'une aventure de vie après tout on
n'est pas artiste pendant une heure et
demie les quelqu'un d'autre pendant la
journée
donc moi je ne ferais pas ce métier là
s'il n'est pas de cette manière là quoi
ça m'intéresse pas d'aller faire des
mises en scène à droite à gauche
donc ça doit se vivre au jour le jour en
plus il ya le fait le fait travailler
des chevaux ça c'est un peu comme dans
les campagnes on a besoin de vivre à
côté des animaux parce que c'est un peu
comme des enfants faut s'en occuper
24h et bonnes vacances comme on dirait
campagne j'ai toujours aux gens de ma
compagnie vous avez choisi de travailler
zingaro les choux on a choisi pour eux
donc encore plus de respect avec eux ça
va être pareil à versailles vous
cherchez un endroit pour mettre des
caravanes aussi les élèves seront
caravane sur la r1 oui parce qu'en plus
j'appelle ça un peu une compagne écoles
s'agit pas seulement de former de la
technique de forme et l'artistique nous
s'il donnait à donner à l'esprit aux
gens qui ont un esprit j'ai l'intention
de rapports et inventer de nouvelles
formes d'école aussi parce que moi j'ai
jamais une école jamais suivi des
copains autodidacte avant ça m'intéresse
alors il ya un côté comme ça dans tout
le monde vit ensemble et vous avez tous
des pseudo vous on vous appelle bartabas
votre énoncé clément marty vous êtes né
en 57 est votre premier contact avec les
chevaux c'est vrai c'était sur un champ
de courses
non non non c'était comment non je vous
garantis commencé à travailler dans les
courses oui ouais je sais pas j'ai dû
voir à jus montage à l'âge de 80 comme
ceux jugés pas vraiment de 2 j'ai
toujours d'où vient ma passion des
chevaux il faudrait demander un
psychanalyste et je cherche pas vu c'est
bizarre parce que votre père était
architecte mermaids a donc amélioré bon
voilà c'était pas oui c'est pour ça que
c'est une passion du passion ça
s'explique pas vous y êtes choqué quand
vous êtes sceptiques entretuer grandir
je venais d'être entraîneur là oui c'est
vrai alors moi entraîneur je voulais
aussi que j'ai arrêté vite ce que j'ai
compris que est elle plus entraîner le
propriétaire du cheval
et puis vous avez un accident de
deux mobylettes vous étiez passagers
vous êtes cassé les deux jambes c'est ça
aussi qui vous a calmé sur le nom mais
disons que ça m'a permis de dons sous
une table de la vie ou enfin les hasards
de la vie comme je dis toujours je crois
que je crois beaucoup au hasard donc des
choses vous amène à faire les choses que
n'y a pas vraiment de
on tourne autour du hasard donc on le
rencontre on tape sur des murs on passe
à côté
évidemment on arrive quelque part c'est
comme un labyrinthe sinon est alors dont
vous avez créé en 76 une première une
première troupe vous allez 19 ans à
l'époque 100 chevaux c'est une troupe de
théâtre donc vous avez le chapeau rouge
à 4 ans porte et voit la tête remporter
chaperon rouge avignon et puis après du
spectacle de rue vous avez fait beaucoup
d'heures même temps on a beaucoup
travaillé dans la rue j'ai commencé dans
la rue en fait ça m'a appris des choses
parce que ça m'a appris ça c'est une
philosophie que je garde toujours c'est
de dire quand on fait des spectacles
vivants doit pas de poète maudit quoi
c'est on veut pas dire moi je suis
génial le public est content il doit se
passer quelque chose pendant une heure
et demie c'est ce qu'annonce dans la rue
et d'attirer l'attention de gala donc ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut faire des
concessions sur ce qu'on a envie de dire
par contre c'est pour moi c'est ça le
sens de la mise en scène on doit se
soucie d'eux que l'émotion parce que les
gens comprennent ce qu'on veut dire donc
ça pour moi c'est indispensable
à l'époque vous avez craché du feu non
moi je cracherais pas du fumeur a déjà
fait on avec la faisait alors vous
avaient cofondé un cirque s'appelle
cirque aligre s'angoisse bomba cc on a
beaucoup écrit là-dessus tsonga rolala
un peu le fer de lance du nouveau cirque
entre guillemets ça je suis pas du tout
d'accord mais par contre c'est vrai que
circa liga était à ça a été un élément
très important de l'influencé beaucoup
surtout en espagne la fura dels baus
tout ça c'est des gens qui ont éclaté en
voyant le cirque à lire un petit peu on
n'a jamais joué à paris alors ça c'était
une expérience assez courtes qui a duré
quatre ans très forte et qui m'a
beaucoup appris deux choses et tu m'as
appris notamment que le ciel n'est pas
un art majeur dans la mesure où c'est un
assemblage de différents artistes qui
est un programme si vous voulez il s'est
passé comme un groupe de rock c'est
qu'on était cinq personnalités fortes
qui ont fait un spectacle génial et qui
n'ont jamais été capables d'en faire un
deuxième parce que chacun avait ses
intérêts la leçon l'autre les rats
l'hôte le trapèze et c'est bon on s'est
réunis ensemble n'a jamais pu mettre un
sixième comme les groupes de rock quand
tu veux rajouter un il faut se rapporter
à l'état 90 avec les maires non
c'est un saut alors ceci calibre est ce
que c'est un petit peu le moment où il
ya un espèce de retour à l'humilité
d'anciens parce que le sentiment que
j'ai eu quand je suis la première fois
au théâtre zingaro
c'est un retour à l'humilité sur des
poules qui marche et autour il y avait
des années avec des oies quelque chose
comme ça de très par opposition aux cd
très provocateur opposition à pindères à
médrano calixa a donné la fera d'elle
tout archaos ou safari mais l'absence de
province c'était ce que j'appelais la
provocation amoureuse que c'était un peu
en réaction par rapport au site pour les
enfants coincés
d'accord on se casse et à faire un
spectacle donc on n en faisait une prime
toujours une espèce de parallaxe est
provocante assez brutale assez violent
et les gens qui passent elles pas en
fait il y avait beaucoup d'humour mais
fallait passer ce palace est d'accord
pour rentrer dedans quoi c'était à nîmes
vous avez vécu en camargue enfin vous
avez des bonnes périodes et tauromachie
j'ai voulu toréer à cheval oui oui
absolument et non mais à un moment vous
avez un problème c'est qu'à un moment
votre c'était bousquet à l'époque était
qui était le maire de nîmes et à
l'époque vous avez vécu dans les arènes
de santé au début de cigares au cinéma
parce qu'en fait on a répété le tout
début de zynga rhône a répété chez simon
casas qui était le directeur des arènes
de nîmes à l'époque et maintenant un
nouveau d'ailleurs et dans sa propriété
comme ça à bellegarde et puis on a
commencé au festival de sigma bordeaux
là où s'était arrêté à l'img d'ailleurs
que je serai toujours redevable parce
que c'est grâce à lui qu'on a pu
vraiment démarré et ensuite on avait un
trou de quatre mois avant d'un contrat
suivant était à madrid quatre mois après
et donc j'ai appelé bousquet j'y vois là
on cherche un terrain où stationner on
au début tu es complètement et lui s'est
pas dégonflé m'a donné les clés des
arènes et on a vécu dans ce qu'on
appelait notre hlm roman c'est insensé
et vous avez participé aux cérémonies du
mariage de mourousi c'est pas ça qui
vous a quand même que de connaître parce
que quand même beaucoup de gens qui
étaient venus de paris salehi garros et
un travail de deux c'est un travail de
long terme moi j ai une vie on n'y a pas
de moment
moi je suis content la notion de dire
souvent les artistes âgés gallery et
puis un jour on m'a tellement fait que
ça a démarré
non pour moi peut-être les plus beaux
moments de ma vie c'est même céder tout
début parce que et pour moi il ya
toujours la même énergie sûre qu'avant
enfin les galères et votre dix mille
balles maintenant pour trouver améliorée
énergie la même le jeu tu as plus moteur
là ce petit chemin dans la tête c'est
terminé pour continuer merci avec notre
coup de coeur pour lâcher les chiens
devancé van hamme 7/15 aventures de xiii
célèbrent leurs 18 ans de carrière de
l'amnésique les plus mémorables de
l'histoire de la bd
karine roy est allé retrouver les
souvenirs du futur magnéto 63 ans le
flegmatique jean van hamme c'est un peu
le paul loup sulitzer de la bibli
thorgal largo winch les maîtres de
l'orge 13 et même les derniers blake et
mortimer tous ces scénarii deviennent
des best-sellers lorsqu'il est temps
qu'on nous sommes ici pour le quinzième
album de 13 c'est une vraie star adulée
par des milliers de femmes et george
sont des fans calme sommes là c'est
exact de cinéma ne sont pas non plus des
chances et de phoques
je crois que personne ne va me déchiré
ma chemise j'espère que non parce que je
n'avais la culture shock et pourtant
pour la sortie de lâcher les chiens tiré
à 150 mille exemplaires son éditeur a
même organisé un super coup de pub en
réunissant les lecteurs les plus
fanatiques autour d'une sorte de quiz où
le grand gagnant on voyagera à travers
le monde sur les traces du héros
mythique 13 et où est créée en 1984 la
série est aujourd'hui culte pourtant
l'idée de départ est très simple un
jeune homme amnésique se lance à la
recherche de son identité
alors quelles sont les raisons d'un tel
succès
l'amnésie ça permet
je dirais aux lecteurs de découvrir les
choses exactement en même temps que le
personnage
sauf que ceux qui découvrent ne peut
être pas la vérité et la série est
devenue finalement beaucoup plus en jeu
entre les lecteurs et nous les auteurs
vont demander oui mais quelle ficelle de
matinée encore tiré moi j'essaie de
jouer en décembre ont ils s'imaginent
que je dirai quelle ficelle quelle
ficelle pourrait tirer à laquelle nous
attend en fait 13 c'est une vraie bd
interactive qui s'adresse à toutes les
générations fait une aventure
spectaculaire s'est fait que monsieur
tout le monde quoi complique pas la vie
des gens avec de grands mots de plus on
a greffé d'économie politique jean van
damme est passionné par les intrigues
stratégie gouvernementale
la force de 13 c'est aussi ces allusions
caustique et des faits réels
l'assassinât de kennedy le maccarthysme
la guerre du vietnam a bien évoqué ce
que j'appelle des traumatismes
américain j'ai tendance à dénoncer
l'abus de pouvoir et je crois que le
lecteur est bien seul
ça lui fait plaisir un peu comme à
guignol
de voir que le pouvoir en place une
petite fessée au passage même si ça
sonne bien des bandes dessinées et puis
on vieux briscard le dessinateur et le
scénariste de 13 le communique que par
courrier ou par internet
le premier habite en espagne second en
belgique l'ordure ou tel mot rodez
qu'ils n'ont même plus besoin de se
rencontrer dans les semaines et les mois
entier que c'est quoi que je tanne des
scénaristes être un des seuls qui fait
je sais ce qu'il aime bien dessiné ce
qu'ils n'aiment pas dessiner on la
préfère à moins de faire un bond de 2 cd
réalisé et tout donc on travaille l'un
après l'autre et n'ont pas la cote et de
l'autre la main sur l'épaule de son
camarade ce penchant on habite true
blood c'est sur le quinzième opus de 13
sera encore un best-seller gens vont à
mu revient à tour du monde
il n'a même pas encore penser à
l'histoire de son prochain album dont le
je n'ai pas pris d'abord disputer
l'avant je dois commencer
ah c'est sam en soute et déjà pris
rapidement des canards jaunes interview
critiqué chronique images et reportages
revivez et revoyez le meilleur de la
culture sous toutes ses coutures
on se retrouve pour mon interview
portrait aujourd'hui 10é bridgwater pour
la sortie de son nouveau cd 6 i knew
bonsoir bonsoir
alors c'est un album qui est composé de
morceaux écrits par kurzweil ah oui
alors avec entre autres la mythique
alabama song avec september song et
bilbao song on regarde manitou
[Musique]
non
à donner
et moi
jo
[Musique]
moi
st eloi sobel
[Musique]
dee dee bridgewater donc bilbao song
extrait de thé this news son dernier
album alors les arrangements sont de
cécile bridgwater votre premier mari qui
avait déjà écrit les arrangements de
dire et là et est en effet avant de
parler du nouveau disque on va quand
même dire un mot de sa vous venez de
passer quatre ans à rendre hommage à
ella fitzgerald
quand elle est mort si vous avez
ressenti un grand vide
et finalement vous avez été surprise que
aussi peu de gens qui lui rendent
hommage
samassa m'a vraiment étonné parce que
pour moi et pour beaucoup de gens
c'était une très très grande armée de
moi j'attendais des dommages à droite à
gauche et finalement il n'y avait rien
c'est bref c'est vrai est temps que
essam a spécialement été étonné parce
que ma maison disque vers stefan départ
son manager poux à la fille de gérard
associerait pas oui ces services étaient
fondées pour elle varie away we verve et
l'air va pas faire ça n'a pas fait
sentir et là bas voilà tant que voilà
moi qui arrive la stupide c'est un
disque acheté aussi dire elle alors pour
revenir à kurzweil en fait vous avez
découvert ça en pologne l'an 2000 êtes
invités au centenaire de la naissance de
courchevel
et là vous vous arrivez et émerveillés
par les paras par les chansons qui sont
générale tiré de comédies musicales ou
d'opérettes et qui raconte des histoires
en fait et qui se prêtent beaucoup à la
dramatisation dans l'interprétation et
ça vous à danser le coup du choc
oui c'est vrai en plus les quatre
d'autres femmes avec qui j'ai fait cet
hommage en pologne étaient les
polonaises donc chanté soins polonais ou
en allemand elle j'ai rien compris mais
c'était avec l'émotion je t'aime mais
vraiment iris été transporté je me suis
dit mais comment c'est possible que un
compositeur peut écrire
tellement de décomposition des chansons
qui peut être exprimé dans une telle
façon et une telle différence pour moi
c'est une signe d'un très grand
compositeur parce que je connaissais
très peu de lui avant oui mais là alors
elles sont presque toutes de lui
certaines paroles sont de bertold brecht
évidemment mais pas du jour mais en fait
ils aillent aux vins voilà beaucoup
beaucoup d'auteurs et un seul
compositeur qui est clé kurzweil oui
donc moi je vais choisi les thèmes qui
sont contenus dans l'argonne pour
montrer un peu notre côté parce qu'on a
une image de lui qui est un peu sombre
un peu noir un peu malgré ma oui oui
donc la plupart de ses compositions été
écrit après qui s'est installé aux états
unis et donc il a travaillé avec wayne
bridge et l'honneur dont les paroles
sont meilleurs à gauche oui oui un mec
solin de saneum de neige qui ont été des
auteurs des comédies musicales aux états
unis alors on va parler un petit peu de
vous de votre vrai nom de code wallon
c'est denise oui denis ce gars est venu
c'est pour ça qu'on s'appelle didier
j'imagine finaliste en commander banon
on dit dennis denise aujourd'hui en
france est pas prêt à tout et fait
presque penser là vous étiez à memphis
tennessee est le berceau du rock and
roll et de la soul music mais vous en
faites sur votre berceau se sont plutôt
penché l'effet du jazz et du blues un
exemple parce que votre père si le
trompettiste matthew garrett rien qui
était prof de musique ses saveurs n'y
est pas du temps derrière bien sûr
implémentation des profs de musique et
épilé t il à les accompagner dynaman
refuse tout va très bien et votre mère
ecoutez-la fitzgerald yes et quand elle
était enceinte et vous dites je savais
ce cas tu es avant de savoir parler
ah oui c'est ce qu'elle me dit
pour toujours que c'est la vérité et
maintenant je pense que peut-être il y à
il ya deux vérités dans ce qu'elle dit
parce que j'ai jamais appris à se gâter
j'ai toujours savait faire du skate
notre naturellement être je pensais que
tous les chanteuses de jazz faisait du
scat
oui ça m'a étonné alors pour ceux qui
savent pas ce qu'est le scat parce que
tout le monde le sait glace c'était là
fitzgerald était une grande spécialiste
du scat alors défaite nous un petit bout
comme ça pour voir passer c'est le sycot
passion de drogue de vol d'aidé sont des
syllabes l'a utilisé ça
sa voix sa bouche comme comme un
instrument certaine façon alors à l'âge
de 7 ans déjà vous disiez plus tard je
serai une grande chanteuse et vous
disiez à vos parents une grande
chanteuse internationale et je vous
achèterez une maison ce que vous avez
fait à la fin des années soixante dix
avec l'argent que vous a rapporté le
votre plus gros tubes qui est cette
chanson que vous enregistrez avec white
shark ce qui s'appelle prix shopping
alors racontez nous un peu comment vous
avez rencontré avec charles sais comment
c'est l'idée de la chanson c'est c'est
eh c'est tellement d'histoires mais très
brièvement
on m'a demandé de faire l'ouverture pour
lui pour ce concert qu'il a donné en 87
au palais des sports en même temps moi
je faisais le spectacle les guider au
théâtre gymnase marie bell donc
pour faire l'ouverture moi j'avais cette
idée que la première partie d'un concert
c'était la preuve chauffer public
en attendant l'arrivée de la grande
vedette donc j'ai choisi
j'ai fait un programme assez éclectique
mais le but avec ses chansons étaient
pour chauffer le public et which has il
a beaucoup apprécié sa pas la suite
c'était un monsieur qui était mon
producteur quand j'étais gosse qui a
suggéré à l'abritrage de faire un duo
avec voilà moi j'étais vraiment sur mes
p'tites fesses je dis merci
il a perdu la tête ce monsieur gosse et
curieusement si vous me trouvez la bonne
mélodie
voilà une bonne texte pourquoi pas
s'affirmer dans la mélodie c
papadiamandis cinq écrits souvent les
chansons d'eddy mitchell à qui elle est
très très belles mélodies pour eddy
mitchell et le parolier c'est ronnie
bird qui était ronnie bird qui est une
idole de nos années 65e les cheveux
comme saronni hivernal mais eu qui
maintenant et viennent me up en effet
les faits les paroles voilà et c'est un
succès n'a qui vous a permis d'acheter
une maison à vos parents et de tenir
votre parole d'enfant voilà c'est
toujours important
voilà alors j vous dit être une grande
chanteuse internationale m'enfin c'est
vrai qu'à l'âge de 16 ans vous commencez
par être paraître chanteuse dans la les
clubs de jazz dans la région de detroit
ou votre famille avait déménagé
c'était dur non j'imagine c'est de cette
vie de la cité pas dieu oh bah non
c'était plutôt à ferrique pour moi parce
que d'abord pour l'enfant de pénétrer un
club à 16 ans et on est toujours mineur
à savoir c'était c'était une sorte de
rêve pour moi de voir comment les
adultes se porte
moi j'étais obligé de rester dans la
cuisine avec les cuisiniers et les boss
bourez et puis au moment où il fallait
chanter mon père qui faisait mon chapeau
rond je sais pas comment 10h au japon
j'appelle donc y faisait mais il a dit
mon cher parent il est venu vous emmener
sur scène qui vous rend peu après dans
la cuisine je suis resté avec moi
obligatoire alors à cet âge là bas comme
j'habite exécuté à flines 3 des trois
c'est la ville des moteurs ces motos 100
c'est l'endroit où est née la motown
tamla motown avant de s'installer à los
angeles
et alors là vous allez faire une
audition à l'âge de 16 ans à la moutarde
et on vous dit il faut attendre d'avoir
18 ans parce qu'on est plein de
problèmes avec stevie wonder et qui
était trop jeune
et alors ça casse votre envie en fait
c'est à dire que votre envie de variétés
parce que vous seriez peut-être vers la
variété jackass votre envie de variétés
parce que vous voulez pas attendre je ne
vais pas attendre et puis j'ai ajouté à
mon père que a de toute façon moi je ne
vais pas signer avec motta moi je veux
signer avec capteur que ce parce que
c'était là où a été signé d'accord voilà
comment vous avez échappé à berry gordy
ses amis voilà alors vous été très
influencée au chanter du jazz très
influencé par les par la porte par les
trompettistes et c'est ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure vous utilisez un petit
peu de voix comme une trompette d'une
façon il en soixante dix vous mariez
premier mariage ce n'est trois premiers
matches avec ce n'est pas que c'était ma
vie et oui c'est votre vie cécile
bridgewater qui a fait les arrangements
de saisie ou des désirs et l'a donc vous
le suivez à new york parce qu'il est
engagé par horace silver djamena hélas
alors là vous allez chanter avec les
plus grands avec sonny rollins avec
dexter gordon 18,6 donc voilà donc là
c'est extraordinaire comme un nom jésus
est né début de ma vie et d'adultes
assez assez chanceuse et c'était
vraiment quelque chose je crois que j'ai
même pas réalisé l'importance du tout
les choses j'ai fait là quand on cite
ces trois noms la cbc surréaliste de
vous retrouver en train de chanter avec
ces gens là quoi alors là bon après
deuxième mariage avec un metteur en
scène qui s'apaise de gilberte mosys qui
le perdent china comment elle va
d'ailleurs votre faim avaient très bien
être 20 est à son troisième du talent
aussi
merci oui bien sûr alors lui bon le
malheureux est mort en 95
vacances air et c'est là d'ailleurs que
votre fille pour ça que 10 à votre fille
s'est lancée dans le r'n'b à ce moment
là parce que
jusque là je n'ai pas trop envie pilat
les parties à ce moment là dessus c'est
à dire que pendant qu'il était malade
gg je voyais que j'avais beaucoup de mal
à s'exprimer
donc je lui demandé de décrire ce
sentiment ce papier donc elle est venue
une heure après il m'a donné un bout de
papier et il y avait une peau m qui est
écrit et quand j'ai lu le poème je lui
dis bah china c'est pas un poème c'est
une chanson donc je lui mets avec un ami
à moi a dit wilkins qui est pianiste qui
a un caractère assez doux et je lui
demander de travailler avec elle donc
les week-ends partie chez lui à
travailler et puis par la suite tu c'est
arrivé voilà comment ça commence et on
fait grand malheur la mort de son père
qui la cause finalement de de son destin
de et de chanteuse
alors au milieu des années 80 vous vous
divorcez c'est donc là on est en 95 on
revient en arrière mais délicate wav ou
divorcé d'avec gilberte nazisme et vous
venez en france mais est en france on
vous connaissez en fait parce que votre
première apparition je crois en france
et en 73 à châteauvallon vous êtes
arrivé à châteauvallon le crâne rasé
comme ça comme une espèce de diva noir
festival de jazz de châteauvallon veut
tout le monde vous avez scotché tout le
monde tout le monde vous connaissez
depuis ce moment là alors pourquoi est
devenu en france à ce moment là bas j'ai
travaillé j'ai chanté avec un grand
orchestre jazz
donc quand il faisait les tournées bain
je les accompagnais pour chanter de
trois morceaux
mais quand même c'était mon petit emploi
ouais et samaa permettez de d'abord de
voyage est d'abord de fait et aussi de
faire la connaissance de beaucoup de
gens d'avoir un peu de harris est exposé
de l'exposition devant public
mais la france parce que dans tous les
pays vous avez le visiter c'est celui où
vous avez vraiment envie d'être
j'ai toujours adoré la fin toujours
toujours depuis mon enfance même comme
j'étais une petite fille je me rappelle
j'étais fasciné par les tous les saints
parce que j'étais élève est catholique
donc tous les saints catholiques 4 tous
les français j'ai adoré mes médecins
préférés c'était jeanne d'arc et saint
françois d'assise ouais et saint
christophe et donc sa fin qui sauve qui
peut vous aider à retrouver vos clés si
vous avez perdu
non mais j'ai rêvé de venir ici et je
crois que c'était le même chose et choix
que j'ai fait aujourd'hui vous êtes
marié votre troisième mariage avec un
français
oui mais vous vivez aux usa maintenant
oui deux ans pour des raisons fiscales
parce que vous avez marre de travailler
pour l'état
oui oui c'est ça c'est ça donc mais plus
simplement non pas tout simplement je
voudrais aussi donner une opportunité à
mon mari et mon fils de de découvrir de
connaître l'autre partie de la culture
de mon fils est aussi je voudrais me
reprocher à mes parents donc et depuis
qu'on est là j'ai perdu mon beau père
avec qui j'étais si proche donc on va
rester maintenant je crois que les
imports avance pc c'est ce que dit
chirac mais je crois qu'on est obligé
les enfants cessent de baisser les
impôts et badey que ça c'est fait je
reviens pas d'accord vous allez revenir
à oui j'ai toujours ma maison ici
vous avez l'esprit assez français vous
dit j'ai pas cet esprit de compétition
qu'on les américains si vous êtes
beaucoup plus cools et pas le côté
latrace quoi c'est pas mon esprit oui
moi je moi je me je me sens française je
me sens européen dans mes goûts ma façon
d'être je n'aime pas ce côté compétitif
j'aime pas dans le métier dans le show
business de tout ce côté de marketing de
deux fermes marché de vendre là comme un
produit comme du savon cc s'est passé en
france cela arrive vous savez je sais
comment malheureusement avec maintenant
verve appartient à universal
oui il s'agissait d'un jeu c'est donc
mais je crois que moi j'ai fait partie
des artistes qui luttent quand même pour
que l'art est du l'air donc moi je lutte
pour que le jazz traditionnel reste
quand même traditionnelle que l'on perd
pas cette histoire parce que c'est la
seule chose qu'on a créé aux états unis
c'est le jazz qui se l'est dit que vous
étiez petit vous pensiez vous viviez
tellement dans le jazz que vous pensiez
du jazz est une musique universelle et
quand vous êtes devenu adulte vous êtes
aperçu que le jazz était minoritaire
très très minorés très minoritaire et
aujourd'hui vous pensez quoi de l'état
du jazz ballet jazz et je plusieurs
respecter en europe qu'aux états unis
malheureusement je peux dire maintenant
boudu voyez comme je revis là-bas à
nouveau
je crois que le jazz est un peu mission
quasi maison dix points parce que les
maisons de disques ont décidé fin des
années 90 que ça n'intéressait pas ces
deux personnes donc ils vont éliminer
tous les départements du gers pour tous
les majeurs tous les labels majeur et ça
va être
les indépendants qui vont prendre le
relais interview critiqué chronique
images et reportages revivez revoyez le
meilleur la culture sous toutes ses
coutures enchaînent enfin avec notre
visite de l'expo madame de pompadour et
les arts au château de versailles
jusqu'au 19 mai une rétro qui nous
dévoile la face cachée de la favorite de
louis 15 une maîtresse femme qui a régné
sur les arts autant que sur le roi et
pour yves bélanger ses vice et versa et
magnéto écoutez cours ce sont les
dorures la vie le faste et appartements
royaux
côté jardin place aux frasques et aux
affaires de coeur avec les appartements
des maîtresses c'est ici que oui 15
installe sa nouvelle passion jeanne
antoinette poisson à 24 ans elle devient
la marquise de pompadour
vous reconnaissez l'escalier intérieur
que le 15 empruntait régulièrement pour
aller chez bataille de fond pas de
groupe et nous rentrons dans
l'appartement
un peu d'air pur la vue sur le parterre
du don et le bassin de neptune tout au
fond voilà la vue qu'avait madame de
pompadour de sa fenêtre et c'était une
femme très instruite et très cultivé
c'est ça qui plaisait au roi elle
n'avait pas des quartiers de noblesse
mais elle connaissait la musique elle
connaissait le théâte elle connaissait
la littérature est elle a su distraire
et occuper le roi intellectuellement le
marquis s'impose donc à versailles elle
est la maîtresse déclaré du roi on la
présente même officiellement la reine
à son tour elle fait l'objet d'une cour
où se pressent pour assister à ces
toilettes publiques dans sa chambre
madame de pompadour et la véritable
reine de versailles parce qu'on peut
dire que louis 15 l'a élu pour compagne
c'est sa compagne d'élections et ennemi
avec lui c'est elle qui dirige les
plaisirs de la cour duquel lui a donné
cette possibilité et puis madame de
pompadour et en même temps sa confidente
sa conseillère et elle est l vie
conjugale mans avec lui la maîtresse
royale tisse sa toile dans la jungle de
versailles pour émoustiller louis 15
--les commandes de belles venus un
françois boucher la favorite cultive ses
goûts pour la peinture les arts
décoratifs
elle encourage la création et c'est
aussi très bien mettre en scène son
image comme celle du roi
elle a ce rapport extrêmement original
pour pour son temps de concevoir parfois
les tableaux comme des moyens de
propagande
elle cherche à apparaître en tant que
protectrice des arts s'il protège les
arts c'est pour elle un moyen de faire
rayonner le règne de louis 15 et de
montrer qu en période de paix les ars
peuvent se développer et que par
conséquent comme louis 15 à apporter la
paix la france
du coup c'est une période de faste et de
richesses pour survivre aux pièges de
versailles la marque qui soigne sa
communication à la fiche aux sentiments
religieux lorsqu'elle ne partage plus la
couche royal elle fait savoir qu'elle
est toujours l'ami de coeur du roi un
nouveau statut donc une nouvelle statue
le visage est très typé avec ses yeux
légèrement globuleux le manteau un peu
lourd et répond effectivement aux traits
physiques de la marquise et on a
immédiatement dit que donc cette
figuration d'avoir qu'ils étaient une
incarnation d'amitié et que le rôle de
madame de pompadour avait évolué au sein
de la cour de versailles
la favorite et dont devenu l'ami fidèle
le roi se rend toujours assez soupé
galant dans ses résidences comme l'hôtel
d'evreux devenu depuis le palais de
l'elysée mais mme de pompadour a été la
maîtresse du roi afin la conseillère ou
là ni pendant 20 ans et c'est
véritablement un tour de force il ya
très peu de cas dans l'histoire de la
france où une maîtresse et était en
place aussi longtemps et peu de
maîtresses ont joué un rôle aussi
important que le sien merci mme bélanger
c'est beau à cette époque c'est
magnifique c'est l'expression formidable
mais bon je peux pas en parler parce que
parce qu'on a vu des images puis parce
qu'après tout est au mieux conseillé
aujourd'hui d'avoir ben oui mais plutôt
parler d'elle de ballet vont pas des
ajustements à travers le livre que vient
de sortir une le verre est vide
bien sûr l'expo est au château de
versailles et le livre est intéressant
et venir le vert explore un peu analysé
de façon assez subtil intelligent
elle explique bien que c'est une
intelligence est pas une intelligence
très profonde
c'est une c'est plus une intelligence de
latrines une intelligence de la vie il
ya des choses la vie du comportement
d'une indigence d'attitude intelligence
sociale très forte exigence des gens d
or si profondes qu'elles connaissent
bien psychologie une intelligence
politique qui n'était pas absolument
évidente
ce qui n'empêchait pas mal à pompadour
on verra pourquoi de s'occuper
absolument tout j'aurais bien aimé avoir
du temps pour lire quelques jeux de
quelques quelques extraits j'ai elle
faisait d'absolument tout elle faisait
absolument tout dit 10 16 de 10 les
mémorialistes et là je cite quand même
un passage qui souffrait et extrêmement
édifiant à cet égard elle tranche elle
décide elle regarde les ministres comme
les siens fulmine d'argenson le matin il
reçoit toujours à sa toilette les
personnages les plus importants de
l'état les ambassadeurs les princesses
et quantité de courtisans elle
s'entretient avec les représentants des
puissances étrangères ont n'hésitez pas
à comparer son pouvoir à celui-là
premier ministre elle a une qualité qui
la rend très propre grande affaire c'est
d'être d'un secret impénétrable et c'est
ce sont ces qualités là qui peu à peu
lui ont permis face à un roi très
démissionnaire très paresseux très
mélancolique très dépressif qui n'aimait
pas profondément la politique qu'ils
préféraient la guerre et qu'ils
préféraient les plaisirs
c'est ça qui lui a permis de s'imposer à
tous les niveaux de la politique
notamment à petit tout un fin de sa vie
la politique étrangère les bleus glauque
le combat qu un sens c'est le combat
contre eux contre les parlements les
nominations toutes les nominations
passer par elle et c'est bien le plus
intéressant dans le livre dès 19h
j'ai trouvé et c'est l'analyse
de la relation très particulière qu'avec
alkey qu'elle avait avec le roi lui car
il incite est très intéressant et c'est
extrêmement touchant car il s'agissait
d'abord d'un amour extrêmement
authentique et très très forte jade et
ça je sais les jouets sexuels mais
totalement
c'était beaucoup plus de la tendresse
que de la sensualité
c'est vrai qu'elle était très habile à
prouver elle explique très bien c'est
très habile à provoquer le désir du roi
mais ce n'était pas une affaire au lit
non pas du tout on sent encore plus fort
mais oui alors de temps en temps pour
les quelques aphrodisiaques si la mène
et n'est pas ça profondément et le roi
c'est la sédelle relativement tôt mais
vous m'avez déjà dans la pub lequel
régner sur le lit du roi serait
d'organiser les plaisirs ça c'est
d'ailleurs elle contrôlait après ces six
ou sept ans d'amour assez tendre quand
même et voluptueux bien que ce ne fut
pas une voluptueuse
elle a très bien compris qu'elle ne
retiendrait pas le roi par ses charmes
et qu'il fallait et qu'il fallait
qu'elle trouve des substituts pour le
roi qui était très demandeur
c'est ainsi qu'elle a contrôlé à la fin
de sa vie dans les dix dernières années
de sa vie elle contrôlait les maîtresses
du roi parfois elles étaient s'acoquiner
avec les valets pour qu'ils fournissent
de la chair fraîche au roi et tout ça
comme a dit mme brooks silver et gold to
b 2-3 que mel brooks a tout dit
été ventes historiques s'agissait d'une
chose d'une chaude tendresse dit evelyne
vert je crois que c'était ça et du nain
d'amour qui peu à peu s'est transformé
en une relation très complexe très
profondes réformes ou delà de l'amitié
et de telle sorte qu'elle est devenue
une absolue nécessité pour le roi elle
était l'amie nécessaire elle était à la
fois la menthe la vie la mère la soeur
la conseillère la confidente
il l'a consulté sur tout sujet il ne
pouvait pas se passer d'elle on va
parler avec monsieur jean bien de jouer
le sujet monsieur vitry voilà par le
livre de jean-pierre il s'est à la fois
c'est à la fois une biographie une
déclaration d'amour une plaidoirie de
maître ouvert pour pour guitry c'est
vrai que vous l'adorez quoi bien saisi
de la trêve est l'objet vous êtes bien
parce que non non je vous aime ceux qui
trient ça me semblait un peu excessif
mais enfin je vous aime bien quand on
lit où on aime bien quelqu'un c'est bien
parce que ça voudrait dire un homme je
vous aime ça me gêne ceux qui trient je
vous adore
c'est un jeune élu comme un vil
d'adoration oui c'est vrai qu'il ne veut
aller début de commencement de
d'apporter un grand auteur ensuite il a
été incinéré s'est ensuite il a été tout
même un poète il ya un peu de tout chez
guitry un acteur aussi donc je joue je
suis attendri par guitry que j'ai
rencontré en 48 c'est peut-être pour ça
vous savez quand on rencontre quelqu'un
un joli vous marque
j'ai rencontré deux hommes qui ont
marqué ces jouets et guitry jouvet je
n'ai pas pu malheureusement joué près de
lui je suis rentré aux français mais
j'avais passé une audition très très
longue il m'a reçue pendant une heure
avec 300 a pas autre chose qui va la pta
pas autre chose c'est drôle c'est que
guitry détestez-vous vais me lancer
il a eu tort et j'ai pris ma première
rencontre va ma première rencontre
c'était un moment je venais de faire mes
débuts officiels au français dans
barbier j'entends une voix qui me dit ah
bon et je me dis quel est l'imbécile qui
me fait une blague quand elle s'était
c'était vraiment lui au téléphone je
suis arrivé tout de suite ventre à terre
et j'étais dans le bout du studio lui
dans l'autre bout du nez jusqu'à moi il
m'a expliqué ce que j'aurai à faire
j'étais tellement intimidées tellement
idiot que je lui ai dit mais m je n'ai
pas le costume
alors regardez tenir absolument
ahurissant quel est l'imbécile que j'ai
devant moi
nous tournons dans trois semaines il
m'avait expliqué tout là tout le plan
tout là le or il avait besoin uniquement
d'une chose c'était la tirade de la
calomnie d'un figaro ne s'occupe pas
assez d'asile mais enfin bon il y avait
une entrée en scène s'était coupée au
montage mais il avait la tirade de la
calomnie c'est comme ça que j'ai
rencontrés mais ça a été fascinant parce
que pendant deux jours j'ai tourné près
de lui et je regardais cet homme qui
racontait des histoires il interrompait
le tourne à l'arrêt alors que ça coûte
très cher tout de même cette fois ces
banques là et c'était une des ses
premières manifestations parce que il
avait voulu le jouer la pièce le diable
boiteux il avait été interdit parce que
le théâtre avec une censure ce mandat
est pas le cinéma
donc il y aurait pu tourner le film mais
imaginez après coup bien entendu que cet
homme venait de passer trois années très
difficiles une cruauté abominable
d'abord l'emprisonnement deux jours
avant la libération il est arrêté puis
ensuite 60 jours de prison
ensuite toute la profession qui s'est
retourné contre lui donc il est passé
vraiment un couloir par un couloir
extrêmement t3 jamais eu a aucune
seconde j'ai le sentiment d'une rancoeur
quelconque
il l'a exprimé dans les livres mais pas
dans le complet très occupé c'était
d'une grande élégance
bon et puis son langage aussi était
d'abord son langage est extrêmement
fleuri même ratio de cinéma et est ce
que vous pourriez par hasard déplacer ce
meuble louis 15 qui ne me semble pas
convenir totalement dans l'armée
iman du décor c'est un oui on entend
dépenser dans un frigo team une histoire
merveilleuse qu'il françois girard était
son assistant et et jeu il est il avait
froid enfin bon il était très très très
malade déjà ces banques là donc les
inrocks canaris l'énergie à côté de gier
je vous en supplie françois il fait un
froid horrible ça fait 10 fois que je
demande qu'on ferme la porte du studio
voulez-vous y veiller je vous prie j
avais trouvé le chaque plateau on
apprend dans les connards vous pourriez
pas faire intentions actuellement et il
se pense j -ph il ne dit pas mon texte
voilà le best-of de r d hergé c'est fini
chers amis chers ennemis bon week-end et
à lundi 18 50 pour un nouveau numéro du
sol j'étais de la culture punk eu les
corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou